bon vendredi mesdames et messieurs
mauvaise nouvelle pour les
automobilistes je suis désolé un autre
chantier à venir ne vous bouchez pas les
oreilles et il y aura oui des délais à
prévoir sur les routes cette fois c'est
à dorval à l'aéroport trudeau jean
rejoint vincent maisonneuve et st l'adn
s'apprête à fermer deux des trois voies
du débarcadère on parle pas de
l'échangeur on va parler dans une
seconde on parle beaucoup des
débarcadères débarcadère des départs
vous allez voir sur les images en direct
c'est déjà assez compliqué quand on
arrive ici au débarcadère des départs
qu'on veut prendre un vol vers le canada
ou encore vers l'étranger et bien à
compter de lundi il y aura des travaux
importants faut refaire la dalle de
béton en entier parce que des
infiltrations d'eau donc de trois voix
on va passer à une seule voie sur une
bonne portion ce débarcadère des départs
il ne sera plus possible d'arrêter il
faudra continuer et débarquer un peu
plus loin et revenir à pied par
l'intérieur de l'aéroport
c'est des travaux qui sont devenues
nécessaires en raison de la
détérioration de cette dalle de béton
ce côté d'aéroports de montréal on dit
qu'on va faire de son mieux pour
faciliter la circulation des automobiles
et des gens ce sont principalement les
secteurs des départs internationaux qui
sont affectés on va passer de trois voix
à une voie de circulation
donc dans ce secteur de travaux
évidemment il va être interdit de
s'arrêter
et évidemment pour maintenir la fluidité
on aura des agents de circulation qui
vont s'assurer du respect de
l'interdiction de deux arrêtés ou de
stationner avant de parler de
l'échangeur vincent combien de temps ça
sera ainsi ah oui j'ai oublié de le
mentionner cette importance et à compter
de lundi
et c'est jusqu'à noël jusqu'en décembre
ça va être très long comme comme travaux
bon et puis pas très loin de l'échangeur
dorval c'est un exemple du plume la plus
mauvaise planification sur la planète
peut-être d'un échangeur moins on peut
dire mais owen des bonnes nouvelles vous
savez que le nerf de la guerre c'est de
brancher l'aéroport de montréal à
l'autoroute 20 qui se dirige vers le
centre-ville ou encore vers l'ouest de
l'île de montréal est et vers toronto
est bien là les travaux ont repris et la
bonne nouvelle c'est qu'on s'est enfin
entendu avec les compagnies de choix
faire il ya une entente signée en bonne
et due forme avec le canadien pacifique
et une entente de principe avec le
canadien national ce que ça veut dire ça
c'est qu'on a le feu vert pour
parachever ce vie à dieu que vous savez
la ccir c'est rendu qu'on voit quand on
arrive sur l'autoroute 20 qui naquit
mène nulle part et d enfin il y en a
plus d'obstacles pour parachever ce
viaduc leur vont pouvoir passer beaucoup
plus facilement de l'aéroport jusqu'à
l'autoroute 20 et vice versa mais ça se
frotte ça se fera pas tout de suite
parce que des modifications afin il
faudra voir les plans comme il explique
la porte parole du ministère des
transports
le lien entre l'autoroute 20 est
l'aéroport devrait être complétée donc
en 2017
actuellement ce qu'on est en train de
faire c'est qu'on complète les plans et
devis donc ça devrait se faire d'ici la
fin de l'automne
une fois que ce sera fait on pourra
aller en procédure d'appel d'offres et
débuter le chantier donc fin des travaux
2017 et pour le volet nord on parle
d'une femme pour 2010 n'est pas prêt je
vous rappelle que le décret ministériel
pour lancer les travaux des changeurs
dorval a été signé en 2007
et l'on parle de 2019 pour la portion
nord faudra ensuite travaillé sur la
portion sud qui vont inclure le
transport en commun
peut-être un trait tout ça on n'a pas
fini de voir des travaux dans ce secteur
j'allais dire pour le débarcadère
on pourra prendre le train yang a râlé
repent non le train arrive pourquoi
bayonne young art sous la portion sous
la portion américaine pour les vols
américains en gare elle est là elle est
prête mais il y aura toujours pas très
qui sera le dieu